Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the summer of 1003, a Viking army descended on southern Wiltshire. Their target was the town of Wilton. Wilton was a place of deep symbolic significance to the Anglo-Saxon monarchy. It was the site of a nunnery where many members of the royal family had been nuns. Some of them had become saints. There was no prospect then that the English would cede this holy place to the invading Danes. Sure enough, an Anglo-Saxon army drew up on the hill above Wilton to oppose the Danish advance.
感谢您收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1003 年夏天，一支维京军队降临威尔特郡南部。他们的目标是威尔顿镇。威尔顿对盎格鲁-撒克逊君主制具有深远的象征意义。那里有一座修道院，许多王室成员都曾在此出家，其中一些人后来还成为了圣人。当时，英国人绝不可能将这片圣地拱手让给入侵的丹麦人。果不其然，一支盎格鲁-撒克逊军队在威尔顿上方的山丘上列阵，以抵御丹麦人的进攻。
The man in charge looked down at the Danes spread out below him and then, according to the Anglo-Saxon chronicle, he feigned himself ill and began to retch and vomit and said that he was sick. His bowels loosened, his legs gave way beneath him, He turned and he ran. The entire English army went with him. The Vikings captured Wilton and put it to the torch. Dominic Sandbrook with me. This is not the kind of behaviour that we want to see on Wednesday, is it, from our brave boys on Wembley if they get confronted. Well, when they get confronted by the Danes,
负责的指挥官俯视着下方散开的丹麦人，据《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》记载，他假装生病，开始干呕、呕吐，并声称自己病了。他肠胃失调，双腿发软，转身就跑。整个英格兰军队也随他而去。维京人占领了威尔顿并将其付之一炬。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）与我同在。这不是我们希望在周三看到的那种表现，对吧？如果我们的勇士在温布利球场面对丹麦人时表现成这样……
but if they have to face a penalty shootout. This is such a depressing way to start. I mean, if Gareth Southgate's lads behave like that on Wednesday evening, that would be the worst moment in the history of English sport, surely. You can't imagine Harry Maguire turning and running away. No, no, no, he won't.
但如果他们必须面对点球大战呢？以这种方式开场真是太令人沮丧了。我的意思是，如果加雷斯·索斯盖特（Gareth Southgate）的弟子们在周三晚上表现成那样，那绝对是英格兰体育史上最糟糕的时刻。你无法想象哈里·马奎尔（Harry Maguire）会转身逃跑。不，不，不，他不会的。
Pretending to be sick. No. But I think it does draw attention to the way in which, I mean, we've, so we went on Adrian Charles to talk about Anglo-Scottish rivalry, which obviously has a very distinguished pedigree. And we've done a podcast on Anglo-German rivalry. But I reckon in some ways, this is the oldest rivalry of all. And I say that because England and Denmark are, of all the countries that are playing
假装生病。不。但我认为这确实引起了人们对某种方式的关注，我的意思是，我们之前在阿德里安·查尔斯（Adrian Charles）的节目中谈到了英格兰与苏格兰的竞争，这显然有着非常显赫的渊源。我们也做过关于英格兰与德国竞争的播客。但我认为在某些方面，这是最古老的竞争。我之所以这么说，是因为在所有参加欧洲杯的国家中，英格兰和丹麦拥有最悠久的连续历史。
in the Euros, are the ones with the oldest continuous history. Yeah, but before we get into the elements of that history, I mean, there's an argument, isn't there, that England was created. I mean, we've talked before about how Britain was created as an anti-French kind of enterprise. Couldn't you argue that England exists because of the Danes, that England was created as an anti-Danish sort of conglomeration? Absolutely, because it's Danish invasion that essentially destroys the kind of patchwork of Anglo-Saxon kingdoms that had previously existed. So Northumbria, Mercia, East Anglia all get demolished. The only one that holds out, I'm proud to say, wessex the kingdom of the
是的，但在我们深入探讨那段历史的要素之前，我的意思是，有一种观点认为英格兰是被“创造”出来的，不是吗？我的意思是，我们之前谈过英国是如何作为一种反法事业被创造出来的。难道不能说英格兰的存在是因为丹麦人吗？英格兰是作为一种反丹麦的集合体被创造出来的？绝对是这样，因为正是丹麦人的入侵从根本上摧毁了之前存在的盎格鲁-撒克逊王国拼图。所以诺森布里亚、麦西亚、东盎格利亚都被摧毁了。唯一坚持下来的，我很自豪地说，是威塞克斯王国，也就是……
wessex where i come from what about mercia mercia held out didn't it no it's king runs away all right i'm afraid i'm afraid um but i i grew up just outside wilton so that's why i'm very familiar with that particular story yeah and it's heroic king alfred um his heroic son edward his heroic daughter athelflad his his heroic grandson Athelstan. They lead the fight back against the Danes and the fight back enables them to kind of reconstitute Wessex as the kingdom of England. So before we get into all this and all the events of that story, they rock up at Lindisfarne, don't they the most one of them used to be one of the most famous dates in in english history um so what year what year is that they arrive and they ravage the monastery and stuff seven nine three and at that point so here's my question as a complete and utter non-specialist when i learned about that um at school or in the sort
威塞克斯，我来自那里。那麦西亚呢？麦西亚坚持住了，不是吗？不，它的国王逃跑了。好吧，恐怕是这样。嗯，我在威尔顿郊外长大，所以我对那个特定的故事非常熟悉。是的，还有英雄阿尔弗雷德国王、他英勇的儿子爱德华、他英勇的女儿埃塞尔弗莱德、他英勇的孙子埃塞尔斯坦。他们领导了反击丹麦人的战斗，这场反击使他们能够将威塞克斯重建为英格兰王国。所以在我们深入探讨所有这些故事之前，他们出现在林迪斯法恩，不是吗？那是英格兰历史上最著名的日期之一。那么，他们到达并蹂躏修道院的那一年是哪一年？793年。在那一点上，作为一个完全的外行，我的问题是，当我上学时，或者通过我们之前在儿童历史那一集中谈到的“瓢虫丛书”了解到这一点时……
of through the ladybird books that we were talking about in the children's history episode um the words vikings and danes were used kind of interchangeably are these people from denmark are they danes that's a really really good question and one that is very difficult to answer because um these kind of markers in early medieval history are incredibly slippery really really hard to pin down so they're described as northmen but right swedes were called northmen uh but northmen are also danes um danes um are so in poetry are often jutes um the jutes say to asser the biography of of alfred are are goths so there's an incredible sense of confusion about it yeah so so essentially the danes in in um in the anglo-saxon period
“维京人”和“丹麦人”这两个词似乎是可以互换使用的。这些人来自丹麦吗？他们是丹麦人吗？这是一个非常非常好的问题，而且很难回答，因为中世纪早期的这些标签极其模糊，真的很难界定。他们被描述为“北方人”（Northmen），但瑞典人也被称为“北方人”。但“北方人”也是“丹麦人”。在诗歌中，“丹麦人”通常是“朱特人”（Jutes）。阿塞尔（Asser）在阿尔弗雷德的传记中说“朱特人”是“哥特人”（Goths），所以这里面存在着令人难以置信的混乱。是的，所以本质上，在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的丹麦人……
they are northmen in general say what we would call vikings yeah um they are that they're they're they're members of the of uh the war bands that attack France. So the Vikings attack France. So they are called Danes. And they obviously later become Normans, don't they? Yeah. So Normans are also called Danes, confusingly. The Danes are, in the English context, are the people who invade England, who carve it up, who then get given a chunk of territory that comes to be called the Danelaw. They are also inhabitants of Denmark. And that's why I say that it's not just England,
他们通常被称为“北方人”，也就是我们所说的维京人。是的，他们是袭击法国的战团成员。所以维京人袭击法国，他们被称为丹麦人。他们显然后来变成了诺曼人，不是吗？是的。所以诺曼人也被称为丹麦人，这很令人困惑。在英格兰的语境下，丹麦人是入侵英格兰、瓜分英格兰，然后获得一块后来被称为“丹麦法区”（Danelaw）领土的人。他们也是丹麦的居民。这就是为什么我说这不仅仅是英格兰的问题……
it's also, in a sense, the Viking Age creates this unitary kingdom of Denmark, which is also very, very ancient. And that's why this kind of rivalry is is is so fascinating intriguing and can be and in fact can be traced back even further than um than the viking invasions because of course the danes appear in beowulf which yeah tell us about beowulf okay so so so beowulf is um the kind of the greatest epic in old english and we don't know when it's written down so there are kind of various alternatives maybe it's it's very early Maybe it's the time of Alfred. Maybe it's the time of, it's in the 10th century. We're not sure. But it doesn't actually feature anyone from England. But it does feature Beowulf, who's a Geat from southern Sweden, who goes to see a king called
从某种意义上说，维京时代也创造了这个统一的丹麦王国，它也非常非常古老。这就是为什么这种竞争如此引人入胜，事实上，它甚至可以追溯到维京入侵之前，因为丹麦人当然出现在《贝奥武夫》中。是的，给我们讲讲《贝奥武夫》吧。好的，所以《贝奥武夫》是古英语中最伟大的史诗，我们不知道它是什么时候写下来的，所以有各种各样的说法，也许它很早，也许是阿尔弗雷德时代，也许是10世纪。我们不确定。但它实际上并没有以任何英格兰人为主角。但它确实有贝奥武夫，一个来自瑞典南部的耶阿特人（Geat），他去见了一位名叫……
Hrothgar, who is the king of the Danes. At Herod. At Herod, which then provides the model for Tolkien's, the Hall of Théoden in Lord of the Rings. Meduseld. But also there's a figure in Beowulf who's called Hegelac, who is described by Gregory of Tours, the Frankish writer, as invading and attacking Gaul in the 6th century.
赫罗斯加（Hrothgar）的国王，他是丹麦人的国王。在赫奥罗特（Heorot）。在赫奥罗特，这后来为托尔金《指环王》中希优顿（Théoden）的宫殿提供了原型。美杜塞德（Meduseld）。而且《贝奥武夫》中还有一个叫赫格拉克（Hegelac）的人物，法兰克作家图尔的格雷戈里（Gregory of Tours）描述他在6世纪入侵并袭击了高卢。
So actually the roots of the Danes, as raiders, as poets, as having kind of interaction with the English, is even older than the age of Alfred and even older than the attack on Lindisfarne. So that's why this is, for anyone with a sense of history, the sight of Danish fans in the stands with their Viking horns and their bristling blonde beards is very exciting. Well, I was about to say our ancestors would have regarded this with utter terror, wouldn't they?
所以实际上，丹麦人作为掠夺者、诗人，以及与英国人互动的根源，比阿尔弗雷德时代甚至比林迪斯法恩遇袭还要古老。这就是为什么对于任何有历史感的人来说，看到看台上戴着维京头盔、留着浓密金胡须的丹麦球迷是非常令人兴奋的。好吧，我正想说，我们的祖先会对此感到极度的恐惧，不是吗？
Because, of course, they learned to dread the sight of the dragon ships and the raiders pouring off the ships. But I say our ancestors but you know there's been tons of sort of studies of dna and stuff aren't i mean isn't there a case that basically this is this is a family a family row really because a lot of us are danes one way or another well i mean interesting that's a point made by um admiral nelson who i'm sure we'll come to later in the podcast. He famously attacks Copenhagen in 1801,
因为他们当然学会了畏惧龙船和从船上涌出的掠夺者的身影。但我说“我们的祖先”，但你知道，已经有很多关于DNA之类的研究了，不是吗？难道没有一种情况是，这基本上是一场家庭纠纷吗？因为我们很多人在某种程度上都是丹麦人。嗯，有趣的是，纳尔逊海军上将（Admiral Nelson）也提到了这一点，我相信我们稍后会在播客中谈到他。他于1801年著名地袭击了哥本哈根……
sinks the Danish fleet. And then shortly after he's done that, he writes a letter to the Danish authorities in which he hails them as the brothers of Englishmen, the Danes, which is very fraternal of him. I bet they forgave him for that then. Yeah, but there's a measure of truth to it. That of course, as with the Scots, as with the Germans, this isn't just a story of rivalry.
击沉了丹麦舰队。在那之后不久，他写了一封信给丹麦当局，称他们为“英国人的兄弟”，这对他来说非常有兄弟情谊。我敢打赌他们当时原谅了他。是的，但这其中有一定道理。当然，就像苏格兰人、德国人一样，这不仅仅是一个竞争的故事。
This is also, there's this close sense of kinship here. And that's why the start of Beowulf, this famous old English epic, has a Danish setting. Well, I mean, lots of our listeners will probably know, particularly the British listeners, that if you go east in Englandland if you go north and east you get all these places that are called thwait and thorpe and so on at the end of the name and those are the places where the danes settled aren't they they're part of the yeah the dane law the the part of england that was danish and of
这也是一种亲近感。这就是为什么《贝奥武夫》这部著名的古英语史诗的开头是以丹麦为背景的。好吧，我的意思是，我们的许多听众，特别是英国听众，可能知道，如果你去英格兰的东部和北部，你会看到所有这些以“thwait”和“thorpe”等结尾的地名，那些就是丹麦人定居的地方，不是吗？它们是“丹麦法区”的一部分，也就是英格兰丹麦人的那部分。当然，有两个……我作为一个完全的外行和局外人，认为丹麦人在英格兰的征服有两次英雄时期，我对吗？所以有阿尔弗雷德时代的那一次，还有后来我们肯定会谈到的克努特（Knut）。名字很有趣的克努特。是的。阿尔弗雷德生活在所谓的“大北方军队”入侵的背景下，这是一支庞大的战团，首先摧毁了北方的诺森布里亚王国，占领了约克。所以这就是为什么在北方你会有一种非常强烈的丹麦存在感和意识。事实上，他们在那里待了几十年，甚至几个世纪。
course there are two am i right in thinking again as an utter non-specialist and outsider to all this that there were sort of two heroic periods of Danish conquest in England. So there's the one at the time of Alfred and all of that stuff. And then there's later on with, I'm sure we're going to have some fun with, Knut. The amusingly named Knut. Yes. So Alfred lives in the context of the invasion of what's called the Great Northern Army, which is this massive kind of war band which first demolishes the kingdom of Northumbria in the north, occupies York. So that's why in the north you get this very strong kind of Danish presence and sense. They're there for decades, in fact, centuries.
这以约克为基地，不是吗？约克是某种意义上的首都……但他们随后转向东盎格利亚。围绕这一点有一个英雄故事。我们在足球比赛中挥舞圣乔治旗，但我们很容易拥有一个非常不同的标志。我们可以用王冠和两支箭作为英格兰的标志。因为在中世纪的大部分时间里，英格兰的国圣是圣埃德蒙（St. Edmund），他是东盎格利亚人的国王，被维京人、丹麦人俘虏，拒绝背教，拒绝放弃基督教，被丹麦人用箭射死。汤姆，我知道这一点是因为伯纳德·康威尔（Bernard Cornwell）的书里写过。
And this is based in York, isn't it? York is the capital of the sort of... But they then move on East Anglia. And there's a kind of heroic story around this. We wave the flag of St. George at the football, but we could very easily have a very different emblem. We could have a crown and two arrows as the emblem of England. Because the national saint of England for much of the Middle Ages was St. Edmund, who was the king of the East Angles, who was captured by the Vikings, by the Danes, refused to apostatise, refused to give up his Christianity and was shot to death with arrows by the Danes. Now, Tom, I know this because it's in Bernard Cornwell.
在电视剧《最后的王国》（The Last Kingdom）的改编中，他们有一个很棒的场景，我想他们把他挂在教堂里什么的。那是对的。他们一直说：“你的上帝现在在哪里，法林？”这在编年史中有记载吗？是的，确实有。他们砍下了他的头，把他的头扔在树林里，把他的身体扔在别处。
And in the TV adaptation of The Last Kingdom, they have a great scene where he's kind of, I think they hang him up in a church or something. And that's right. They keep saying, you know, where is your God now firing? And this is attested in the Chronicles, is it? This is. It is. And they chop off his head and they dump his head in a wood and they dump his body elsewhere.
他的追随者们来营救他的身体，将其作为圣物保存。但他们找不到他的头。然后他们听到从树林里传来“hic, hic, hic”的声音，那不是有人喝醉了。那是一只狼在用拉丁语喊“这里，这里，这里”。狼站在头颅旁边守卫，他们得以捡起头颅并将其埋葬。所以圣埃德蒙成为了盎格利亚人的守护神，后来也成为了丹麦人的守护神，丹麦人后来皈依了基督教并接受了他。在中世纪的大部分时间里，他都是英格兰的守护神，而且有很多人继续认为他应该成为守护神，其中包括出色的历史学家弗朗西斯·杨（Dr. Francis Young）博士，他写了一本关于……
And his followers come and rescue his body to keep it as a relic. But they can't find his head. And then they hear coming from the wood the sound hic, hic, hic, which isn't someone drunk. It's a wolf crying out in Latin here, here, here. And the wolf is standing guard over the head and they're able to pick up the head and bury it and so saint edmund becomes the patron saint of of the angles and in due course of the danes who become christian in due course and adopt him and he is the the patron saint of england for much of the middle ages and there are lots of people who continue to think that he should be the patron saint among them the the wonderful historian dr francis young who has written an entire book on
圣埃德蒙的整本书，他曾经带我去贝里圣埃德蒙兹（Bury St Edmunds），向我展示了网球场的遗址，据说圣埃德蒙的遗物至今仍埋在网球场下。他非常渴望把它挖出来，但贝里圣埃德蒙兹的网球运动员们对此不太热衷。但我希望他有机会。但无论如何，他在推特上说：“当然，我希望英格兰在对阵丹麦时获胜。但另一方面，如果丹麦人击败我们，这将给我一个借口去制作无尽的圣埃德蒙表情包。”但这非常不祥，因为这是一个英雄失败的故事。这是加扎（Gazza）泪流满面地出局。我的意思是，埃德蒙输了。
st edmund and who once took me to berry st edmunds and showed me the site of tennis court where supposedly um the relics remain to this day under the tennis court he's absolutely itching to dig it up but the tennis players for berry st edmunds are less keen on this. But I hope he gets a chance. But anyway, he tweeted, of course, I hope England win against Denmark. But on the other hand, if the Danes beat us, it will give me an excuse to create endless St Edmund memes. But this is very ominous because this is a sort of heroic failure story. This is Gazza's tears crashing out. I mean, Edmund lost.
我的意思是，他的头被砍掉了。但在我们最近与丹麦的比赛中，我们输了，不是吗？我们以1-0输了。好吧，那是一场友谊赛，我想，是吗？那是一场友谊赛。所以，当圣埃德蒙被射死时，我们输给了维京人、丹麦人，但我们最终赢了，因为丹麦人都皈依了基督教并接受他为圣人。所以我认为这是一个积极的信号。我认为，有圣埃德蒙在天堂俯瞰，一切都会好起来的。好吧，这就是我要问你的。那么，那些参与杀害埃德蒙并领导大北方军队的人，正如我从观看《最后的王国》所记得的那样……
I mean, his head was cut off. But we didn't, in our most recent match against Denmark we lost didn't we we lost 1-0 well it was a friendly I think wasn't it was it a friendly so so we lost against the Vikings against the Danes when St Edmund got shot to death but we then ultimately won because the Danes all got converted to Christianity and accepted him as a saint so I see it as a positive sign I think I I think that with St. Edmund looking down from heaven, everything's going to be okay. Well, this is what I was going to ask you. So the fellows who are involved with the killing of Edmund and are leading the great Northern army, as I recall
古斯伦（Guthrum），一个非常忧郁、阴沉的家伙，最终成为了大北方军队的领袖。不是吗？或者至少是这些军阀中最著名的一个。还有一个名字很棒的家伙叫胡巴（Hubba）。胡巴，对。我认为这是英格兰入侵者中最好的名字。是胡巴吗？
from the last Kingdom Watching, Guthrum, who's a very sort of lugubrious, melancholy fellow, and ends up being the leader of the Great Northern Army. Doesn't he? Or at least the most famous of these sort of warlords. There's also a guy with the brilliant name of Hubba. Hubba, right. Which I think is the best name of an invader of England ever. Is it Hubba?
因为在伯纳德·康威尔的书里，他被改名为乌巴（Ubba）。胡巴更有趣。胡巴更有趣。所以古斯伦，这是一件非同寻常的事情，不是吗？他到达英格兰，你知道，戴上历史学家的帽子，你可以想象维京人的入侵显然有一种推拉作用。
Because in Bernard Cornwell, he's renamed Ubba. Hubba is much funnier. Hubba is funnier. So Guthrum, this is an extraordinary thing, isn't it? He arrives in England and, you know, sort of putting the historian's hat firmly on, you can sort of imagine there's obviously a push-pull with the Viking invasions.
他们因为斯堪的纳维亚的土地竞争或其他原因被赶出来，但他们也被英格兰的财富所吸引。他到达后，最终采用了当地的宗教，不是吗？我的意思是，阿尔弗雷德基本上强迫他这样做吗？这就是发生的事情吗？所以威塞克斯王国抵御了某种压倒性的力量。维京人行动迅速、咄咄逼人，而且他们很狡诈，或者至少对西撒克逊人来说，他们看起来很狡诈……
They're driven out because of competition for land or whatever in Scandinavia, but they're also drawn by the wealth of England. He arrives and he adopts the local religion eventually, doesn't he? I mean, does Alfred basically force him to do that? Is that what happens? So the kingdom of Wessex holds out against kind of overwhelming force. And the Vikings are fleet, aggressive, and they're treacherous, or at least to the West Saxons, they seem treacherous because they least to the west saxons they seem treacherous
因为他们基本上不遵守誓言，他们背信弃义的终极标志是他们在第十二夜袭击了阿尔弗雷德举行朝廷的奇彭纳姆（Chippenham），也就是在圣诞节期间。这绝对不是一件好事，这简直是一张红牌。但如果我……你知道，丹麦人不按规则出牌，所以他们不在乎。那就是阿尔弗雷德逃往阿瑟尔尼（Athelney）沼泽的时候。他烧焦了蛋糕。他招募士兵。他率领军队出击。
because they don't basically hold to oaths and the ultimate mark of their treachery is that they attack chippenham where alfred is holding court on 12th night so during the festival of christmas and this is very much not the dumb thing it's it's it's a kind of red card offense really but if i you know the danes aren't playing by the rules so they don't care so that's when alfred flees to the marshes of Athelni. He burns the cakes. He recruits men. He leads an army out.
他击败了丹麦人。他起草了一份条约，古斯伦将成为一名基督徒。他取了基督教名字埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）。他得到了后来被称为“丹麦法区”的领土，基本上就是东盎格利亚、林肯郡。如果你想象麦西亚，从默西河到泰晤士河画一条线，他得到了那条线东边的一半。阿尔弗雷德在进攻中获胜后，通过建立一条被称为“堡垒”（burhs）的防线巩固了他的领导地位，这些堡垒是沿着从默西河到泰晤士河那条线上的防御性集镇。维京人无法真正突破这一点，最终他们在这道强大的防线面前碰得头破血流。是的，然后……
He defeats the Danes. And he draws up a treaty whereby Guthrum will become a Christian. He takes on the Christian name of Athelstan. And he gets what comes to be called the Danelaw, which is basically East Anglia, Lincolnshire. And if you imagine Mersey with a line drawn from the Mersey down to the Thames, he gets the eastern half of that. And Alfred then, having won in attack, then kind of consolidates his lead by building a great line of what are called burrs, kind of fortified market towns market towns again along that line from the Mersey down to the Thames and the Vikings can't really break through that and in due course they kind of smash themselves and smash themselves against this mighty line of defense yeah and then uh rather
就像周六晚上一样，英格兰发起进攻。阿尔弗雷德的女儿、麦西亚人的女领主埃塞尔弗莱德（Aethelflaed），我认为她是英格兰历史上最英勇的女性政治人物，她的兄弟、西撒克逊人的国王爱德华，他们发起进攻。他们最终征服了亨伯河以南的所有英格兰领土。然后是阿尔弗雷德的孙子埃塞尔斯坦，他征服了诺森布里亚，从丹麦人手中夺回了它。这并不是一种……实际上，这就是英格兰的缔造。英格兰随后成为了一个联合王国。丹麦人确实卷土重来。他们重新占领了约克。他们实际上占领了亨伯河以南相当大的一片土地，但他们被推了回去。当埃塞尔斯坦的侄子……
like on Saturday night um England go on the attack um and athelflat who is alfred's daughter the lady of the mercians i think the most heroic female political figure in in english history her brother edward who's the king of the west saxons they go on the attack um they they end up conquering all of england south of the humber um and then it's athelstan who is alfred's grandson uh then conquers northumbria and takes it back from the Danes. And it's not a kind of, effectively, this is the making of England. England then becomes a United Kingdom. The Danes do make a comeback. They recapture York. They actually capture quite a large swathe of land south of the Humber, but they get pushed back. And by the time that Athelstan's nephew,
埃德加（Edgar）成为国王时，英格兰已经早早地统一了。埃德加所做的是坚持一种统一的货币。所以所有的白银都直接处于王室控制之下。这是一种对税收、对货币的控制程度，在西欧是绝对独一无二的。唯一也在做这件事的其他帝国是西班牙南部的安达卢斯（Al-Andalus）和拜占庭帝国。但没有其他罗马帝国的继任王国在这样做。这使得英格兰看起来很富有。它使它看起来很强大。但这有点像，我不知道，口袋里露出一串钻石项链走在黑暗的小巷里。因为，你知道，抢劫犯，嗯，他们在爱尔兰。
Edgar, becomes king, England is precociously unified. And what Edgar does is to insist on a kind of unitary currency. So all the silver comes directly under royal control. And that's a kind of degree of control over taxation, control over money that is absolutely unique in Western Europe. The only other empires that are doing it are Al-Andalus in the south of Spain and the Byzantine Empire. But no other kind of successor kingdom to the Roman Empire is doing it. And this makes England seem rich. It makes it seem strong. But it's a bit like kind of, I don't know, walking down a dark alley with a kind of diamond necklace sticking out of your back pocket. Because, you know, the muggers, well, they're in Ireland.
所以维京人建立了都柏林，“黑池”（Blackpool），都柏林就是黑池。但他们当然也跨越了北海。所以他们仍然盯着英格兰。在爱德华的儿子、埃塞尔雷德（Æthelred）的统治下，他准备不足、建议不当，丹麦人又回来了。在我们谈到这一点之前，汤姆，你轻描淡写地略过了一些我认为非常可耻的事情，那就是埃塞尔弗莱德和爱德华与丹麦人进行的伟大战斗。
So the Vikings have founded Dublin, the Blackpool, Dublin is Blackpool. But they're also, of course, across the North Sea. So they've still got their eyes on England. And under the reign of Edward's son, Æthelred, unread, ill-advised, the Danes come back. Before we come to that, Tom, you skated over something I thought pretty shamefully, which is that the great battle that Aethelflaed and Edward, I think, fight against the Danes.
那是埃塞尔弗莱德和她的名声。爱德华与此无关。他来晚了。他是事后才赶到的吗？是在伍尔弗汉普顿，对吧？那是泰顿霍尔（Tettenhall）战役，或者有些人说是韦登斯菲尔德（Weddensfield），所以那是伍尔弗汉普顿的两个不同部分。我喜欢说泰顿霍尔，因为我的祖父母曾经住在泰顿霍尔。
It's Aethelflaed and her fame. Edward has nothing to do with it. He pitches up late. Does he pitch up afterwards or something? It's in Wolverhampton, isn't it? It's the Battle of Teton Hall, or some people say Weddensfield, so those are two different parts of Wolverhampton. I like to say Tettenhall because my grandparents used to live in Tettenhall.
但韦登斯菲尔德更浪漫。嗯，那是沃登斯菲尔德（Wodensfield）。是的。所以维京人发动了一场伟大的……所以埃塞尔弗莱德入侵了林肯郡，夺回了一位圣人的遗物，然后她将其埋葬在格洛斯特，作为一种精神上的“星球大战”，一个铁穹顶，用超自然力量绝对保护它。
But Weddensfield is more romantic. Well, it's Wodensfield. Yeah. Yes. So the Vikings have launched a great... So Athelflaed has invaded Lincolnshire to grab back the relics of a saint, which he then buries in Gloucester to serve as a kind of spiritual Star Wars, an iron dome, to absolutely protect it with supernatural power.
丹麦人对此非常生气，于是他们发动了大规模入侵。他们抢劫并焚烧。当他们穿过伍尔弗汉普顿（未来的伍尔弗汉普顿遗址）返回时，他们在一条河边遭到袭击，在盎格鲁-撒克逊人的长矛雨下丧生。说实话，很多客队球迷去伍尔弗汉普顿时也会发生这种情况。所以，汤姆，在这一点上，丹麦人和英国人，英国人已经开始把自己视为英国人了，不是吗？这在某种程度上是……
And the Danes are so cross about this that they then launch a massive invasion. They loot and burn. As they're going back through Wolverhampton, the future site of Wolverhampton, they get attacked at a river and they perish beneath a rain of spears, the Anclay Saxon. I mean, that happens to a lot of visiting fans when they go to Wolverhampton, to be fair. So, Tom, at this point, right, the Danes and the English, the English have started to see themselves as the English, haven't they? It's kind of in
与丹麦人对立，我想。他们有多大不同？因为在最著名的虚构版本中，也就是现在的伯纳德·康威尔的书里，有一种文化冲突的感觉，即喜欢喝酒、玩乐和杀人的异教徒丹麦人，与稍微严肃、虔诚、一心只想着上帝和修道院的英国人之间。这是否植根于真正的文化差异？还是他们会把对方视为某种同胞，
opposition to the Danes, I suppose. How different are they? Because in, let's say, the most famous fictional iteration of this, which is now the Bernard Cornwell books, there is this sense of a kind of culture clash between the pagan Danes who like, you know, drinking and having fun and killing people and the slightly more sort of serious and pious English who are all about kind of God and monasteries and stuff. Is that rooted in a genuine cultural difference? Or would they have recognized one another as kind of brethren,
如果你愿意的话，实际上有着相似的根源、相似的习惯等等？答案是什么？在阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人进行的战争期间，我认为确实存在一种差异感，而且在阿尔弗雷德时代、在古斯伦和他的追随者受洗之前，这种差异要大得多。但即使在他们受洗之后，他们仍然是某种外来人物。但他们适应得非常快。他们变得非常虔诚地信奉基督教，因为他们看到基督教的上帝基本上击败了他们。他们受到了更强大的西撒克逊君主制的文化和经济影响。所以我有一枚很棒的硬币，是我拥有的，是在罗马的一堆硬币中发现的，是一个来自东盎格利亚的丹麦人去朝圣时带去的。这是一个赝品。这是丹麦法区的丹麦人制造的，用来模拟爱德华（阿尔弗雷德的儿子）铸造的硬币之一。所以你在那里看到的证据是，他正在去罗马朝圣。所以他已经变得英格兰化了，以至于他采用了英国的宗教，并且在经济上处于从属地位。所以英格兰的文化影响非常大。我的意思是，话虽如此，你确实会听到盎格鲁-撒克逊道德家对丹麦习惯的抨击，其中包括画眼线。哦，那很糟糕。剃掉后脑勺。所以维京人不能留鲻鱼头。
if you like, with actually similar roots, similar habits, all that sort of stuff? What's the answer there the during during the the wars that that alfred and his um heirs fight um i think there is a sense of of difference uh and it it's much greater during the time of alfred before guthrum and his followers get baptized yeah but even once they've been baptized they are kind kind of alien figures. But they adapt very, very quickly. They become devoutly Christian because they see that the Christian God has basically defeated them. And they come under the cultural influence and the economic influence of the much stronger West Saxon monarchy. So I've got a wonderful coin, which I own, which was found in a pile of
对。最糟糕的是，每个星期六都要洗澡。星期六到了，你就得洗澡。眼线和洗澡对我来说看起来非常“新浪漫主义”。嗯，非常女性化。这被强壮而正直的盎格鲁-撒克逊人视为女性化的极致。我从没想过丹麦人是女性化的。我的意思是，如果丹麦听众听到我一直认为……
coins in Rome, taken there by a Dane from East Anglia on pilgrimage. And it's a fake. It's a fake made by the Danes in the Dane law to simulate one of the coins stamped by Edward Alfred's son. So what you see there is evidence, and then he's going on pilgrimage to Rome. So he's become English to the degree that he's adopted the English religion, and he is kind of economically subordinate. So the influence, the cultural influence of England is very great. I mean, having said that, you do get fulminations from Anglo-Saxon moralists complaining about Danish habits, which include wearing eyeliner. Oh, that's bad. Shaving the back of your head. So no mullets for Vikings.
丹麦人是非常有活力、有阳刚之气的角色，他们会很高兴的。显然有很多东西需要梳理。是的，我想在我的潜意识里也是如此。所以让我问你一个关于“丹麦法区”的问题。
Right. And worst of all, having baths every Saturday. When Saturday comes, you have a bath. The eyeliner of a bath seems very new romantic to me. Well, very effeminate. It's regarded as the height of effeminacy
“丹麦法区”，那里的人们是否意识到自己，比如说第二代或第三代，他们仍然认为自己是丹麦人，还是认为自己是英国人？是的，我想是这样。嗯，某种程度上。
by the manly and upright Anglo-Saxons. I never thought of the Danes as effeminate. I mean, if Danes listeners will be pleased to hear that I always have thought
或者这是一个太简单的问题？我的意思是，这种意识往往会随着几代人的更迭而淡化，但显然口语丹麦语的影响在地名中很明显。是的。而且我认为它确实持续了相当长一段时间。但我的意思是，这当然因为丹麦定居者开始接受圣埃德蒙作为他们的……在地名中很明显，而且我认为它确实持续了相当长一段时间。但我的意思是，这当然因为丹麦定居者开始接受圣埃德蒙作为他们的守护神，所以这很复杂，甚至你知道，这进一步表明了它有多复杂……
of the Danes as very vigorous, virile kind of characters. There's a lot to tease out there, obviously. Yeah, not least in my tortured subconscious, I suppose. So let me ask you a question about the Dane law.
是当在埃塞尔雷德统治下，你开始看到丹麦人以越来越多的数量回来。他们是以基督徒的身份回来的。他们已经成为了基督徒，但这并没有阻止他们。埃塞尔雷德“无准备者”（the Unready），我记得在我那本《英格兰国王与王后》或《盎格鲁-撒克逊国王》之类的书里，他的表现非常糟糕。不像我们几周前谈到的约翰王那么糟糕，我们一致认为他，用你的话说，是个混蛋。
The Dane law, are the people there conscious of themselves, let's say their second or third generation, do they still think of themselves as Danes or do they think of themselves as English, would you say? Yeah, I think so. Well, kind of.
但埃塞尔雷德“无准备者”，他是国王里的特蕾莎·梅（Theresa May），不是吗？他基本上是在危机中挣扎。那里出了什么问题？为什么丹麦人会以如此庞大的数量卷土重来？有一本关于他的精彩传记。我的意思是，传记在某种意义上，因为你不能真正用现代意义写传记，利维·罗奇（Levi Roach）写得很好，试图进行修正主义。基本上，他处理的是一手非常糟糕的牌……
Or is that too simplistic a question? I mean, it tends to fade over the generations, but obviously the impact of spoken Danish is evident in the place names. Yes. And I think it does last for quite a while. But I mean, it's certainly complicated by the way that Danish settlers come to accept, say, Edmund as their... evident in in the place names uh and i think it does last for quite a for quite a while but i mean it's certainly complicated by the way that danish settlers come to accept say edmund as their yeah their patron um so it is complex and even you know and it's it it a further sign of how complex it is
而且相对于其他人，他非常有钱。所以他显然做了明智的事情。他试图用钱打发他们。丹麦金（Dane Geld）。这就是著名的丹麦金。是的。但问题是，正如吉卜林（Kipling）后来指出的那样，如果你支付丹麦金，那么……这就是著名的丹麦金。是的。但问题是，正如吉卜林后来指出的那样，如果你支付丹麦金，那么就会有越来越多的人来。
is that when under um athored you start to get get the Danes coming back in increasing numbers. They are doing it as Christians. They've become Christian and it doesn't stop them. Aethelred the Unready, I remember in my Lady Bird, Kings and Queens of England or Anglo-Saxon Kings or whatever it was called. He came out very poorly. Not as badly as King John that we did a few weeks ago, who we agreed was, in your words, a shit.
最终导致了王国被征服的局面。埃塞尔雷德逃往诺曼底，回来后去世了。继位的是他的儿子埃德蒙“铁肩王”（Edmund Ironside），他是一个真正的强力中锋，所以才有了这个绰号。但他基本上与克努特打成了平手。克努特，他后来死在厕所里，据说在这个时期很多人死在厕所里，事实上，这是一个你谈论维京人时的话题。
But Æthelred the Unready, he was the Theresa May of kings, wasn't he? He was just floundering from crisis to crisis, basically. And what goes wrong there? How come the Danes sweep back in such numbers? There is a wonderful biography of him. I mean, biography in the least sense, because you can't really write a biography in the modern sense by Levi Roach, which does a good job at attempt at revisionism. Basically, he's dealt a very tough hand
好吧，我已经在这个播客中两次提到克努特的祖父哈拉尔德“蓝牙”（Harold Bluetooth）了，他不仅因为给蓝牙技术命名而闻名，而且最终在拉屎时被弓箭手射中了屁股。但哈拉尔德“蓝牙”也很重要，他是第一位基督教国王，对吧？他是第一位皈依基督教的国王，所以斯文“叉胡子”（Svein Forkbeard）的儿子，也就是我们在本播客开头提到的袭击威尔顿的人。那是斯文“叉胡子”。克努特据说是基督徒，但这并没有阻止他们变得不那么可怕。他们是一个庞大的北海帝国的统治者。我说的对吗？一个看起来像……
and he's incredibly rich relative to everyone else. And so he obviously, he does a sensible thing. He tries to buy them off. Dane Geld. That's the famous Dane Geld. Yeah. But the problem is, as Kipling goes on to point out, that if you pay Dane Geld, then more the famous Dane Geld. Yeah. But the problem is, as Kipling goes on to point out, that if you pay Dane Geld, then more and more people will come.
北欧最强大的国家之一，如果不是最强大的话。是的。所以“蓝牙”，蓝牙技术以他命名的原因之一是丹麦有这块耶灵石（Jelling stone），哈拉尔德“蓝牙”在上面刻了铭文，他吹嘘自己将人们团结在一起的方式。他的意思是，你知道，南挪威、南瑞典，把他们都团结在一起。他的儿子、孙子随后也征服了英格兰。让我们问问很多听众会问的问题，关于克努特和潮汐。是的。我们有迈克尔·FKA，不是吗？你有那个吗？
And it ends up with a situation where the kingdom gets conquered. Æthelred flees to Normandy, comes back, dies. He's succeeded by his son, Edmund Ironside, who is a proper storming centre-forward, hence his nickname. But he kind of fights to a standstill with with Knut um Knut he then dies supposedly on the on the toilet um quite a lot of people supposedly die on the toilet in this period as a matter of fact this is a theme of whenever you talk about the vikings well it is well I've already mentioned Knut's grandfather
我有。迈克尔·FKA说，非常期待克努特承认英格兰潮汐不可抗拒的力量的类比。是的。但不幸的是，好吧，克努特的……现在，这总是被描绘成克努特是一个笨蛋……
um Harold Bluetooth twice I think on this this podcast as the guy who first of all famously gives his name to Bluetooth technology but also ends up being shot in the arse by an archer while he's having a dump but Harold Bluetooth is also significant he's the first Christian king right he's the first king who converts to Christianity and so Svein Fortbred his son who is actually the guy who leads the attack on Wilton that we began this podcast with. That's Svein Fortbeard. Ankenut are supposedly Christian, but that doesn't stop them being any the less terrifying. They are masters of a huge North Sea empire. Am I right? An empire that looks like
和一个被冲走的傻瓜……不，恰恰相反。但这完全错了，不是吗？恰恰相反。克努特实际上……是他的朝臣们才是傻瓜，而他是智者。所以克努特很可怕，他年轻、刻薄、贪婪得令人难以置信。一旦他成为英格兰国王，他就征收100%的税率，这很严厉，这让丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）看起来像个减税者。他让人们叫苦连天。英格兰一年的全部收入都进了他的国库。
one of the most potent states in Northern Europe, if not the most potent. Yeah. So Bluetooth, one of the reasons why Bluetooth technology is named after it is that there's this stone yelling in Denmark where Harold Bluetooth puts up this inscription where he talks about, he boasts about the way that he has joined people together. And by that he means, you know, South Norway, South Sweden, brought them all together. And his son, his grandson, then move on to conquer England as well. And let's ask the question that a lot of listeners will be asking, which is about Canute and the waves. Yes. We've got Michael FKA, haven't we? Have you got that?
但他随后稍微冷静了下来。下次只要90%。基督教和盎格鲁-撒克逊君主制的传统既有声望又时髦。他想成为其中的一部分。我想这就像彼得·舒梅切尔（Peter Schmeichel）来到曼联一样。是的，还有莫尔比（Mølby），他来到英格兰时带着浓重的丹麦口音，最后……
I have. Michael FKA says, very much looking forward to the Knut acknowledges the inexorable power of the English tide analogy. Yes. But unfortunately, well, Knut's... Now, this is always painted as Knut is an oaf
因为他在利物浦踢了那么多年球，带着利物浦口音。给你，这就是我喜欢看到的。这就是克努特的类比，他成为了基督教君主制的典范。所以他实际上慷慨地资助了威尔顿，有一些关于他和他的王后这样做的精彩插图。关于他……
and a fool who is washed... No, it's the opposite. But it's completely wrong, isn't it? It's the opposite. Knut is actually... It's his courtiers who are the fools and he is the wise man so so Knut is terrifying he's young he's mean he's incredibly rapacious once he's become king of England he imposes a 100 tax rate that's that's harsh that sort of makes Dennis Healy look like a tax cutter. He makes the pips squeak. The whole revenue of a single year in England goes into his coffers.
阻挡潮汐的故事，这是他对一个奉承者说“你什么都能做”的回应。他说：“不，我不能。”所以他命令他的朝廷下来，他把王座放在海滩上，他举起手来阻止潮汐，当然潮汐涌了进来，重点是人类与上帝相比的不足。所以基本上，我认为在某种程度上，他被“英格兰化”了。他后来有两个儿子，哈罗德“兔足”（Harold Harefoot）和哈德克努特（Harthacnut）。然后你就进入了……他们非常无聊。他们基本上没有真正……
But he then slightly calms down. A mere 90% next time. Christianity and the traditions of Anglo-Saxon monarchy are prestigious and stylish. He wants to be a part of it. I guess it's got Peter Schmeichel coming to Manchester United. Yeah and Mulby who arrived in England speaking with a very strong Danish accent and ended
做任何事。他后来被“忏悔者”爱德华（Edward the Confessor）取代。爱德华被哈罗德·戈德温森（Harold Godwinson）取代。然后是威廉征服者（William the Conqueror）。正是在威廉征服者统治下的1069年，也就是黑斯廷斯战役三年后，当另一位名叫斯文的丹麦国王被北方的叛军邀请过来时，发生了最后一次丹麦入侵尝试，他顺着亨伯河而上，占领了约克。威廉推进，叛军逃跑，丹麦人陷入困境，所以他们回到了船上。
with a Scouse accent because he'd played for Liverpool all those years. There you go so that's kind of what I like to see. That's Knut the analogy and he becomes a model of Christian kingship so he actually endows Wilton prodigiously, there's kind of wonderful illustrations of him and his queen doing that. And the story of him
他们再次前往东盎格利亚，就像他们的祖先所做的那样。他们蹂躏了东盎格利亚。威廉征服者支付了丹麦金。他贿赂他们离开。是吗？关于威廉征服者我不知道这一点。是的，他确实这么做了。他们扬帆远去，基本上就是这样。为什么他们再也没有回来？
holding back the tide, it's his response to a flatterer who says that you're capable of doing anything. And he says, no, I can't. So he orders his court to come down and he puts the uh the throne by the on the beach and he holds his hand up to stop the tide and of course the tide comes in and the the point is about the inadequacy of human beings compared to god and so so basically he becomes i suppose to that extent um anglicized he then then has two sons, Harold Harefoot and Harthacnut. And then you're into... They're incredibly boring. They kind of don't really
我想他们已经足够基督教化了，那种传统开始淡化，成为维京人的传统开始淡化。但这也是威廉建立的诺曼君主制的实力和权力，以及所有各个王国之间某种基督教共性的感觉。所以我认为如果我们谈论英丹关系，这确实是两半的比赛。好吧，我正想说，所以上半场是丹麦人把沙子踢到英国人脸上。那么比分是多少？下半场。汤姆，你觉得比分是多少？
do anything. He then gets seated by Edward the Confessor. Edward the Confessor gets seated by Harold Godwinson. Then you have William the Conqueror. And it's under William the Conqueror in 1069, so three years after the Battle of Hastings, that you get the final Danish attempt at an invasion when another Danish king called Svein is invited over by rebels in the north, comes up the Humber, occupies York. William advances, the rebels flee, the Danes are kind of stranded, so they get back in their ships.
我认为是丹麦3-1领先，我想。丹麦3-1。那很糟糕。如果周三半场时是3-1，我会非常失望。好吧，如果是1-3，我会非常失望。但这确实是两半的比赛。这确实是两半的比赛。让我们看看下半场会发生什么。
They go down to East Anglia again, as their forebears had done. They ravage East Anglia. William the Conqueror pays them Dengeld. He bribes them to go away. Does he? I didn't know that about William the Conqueror. Yeah, he does. They sail away, and that is basically it. Why don't they come back ever again?
我们走着瞧。所以他们回到更衣室。加雷斯·索斯盖特可以谈谈，看看休息后情况是否会改变。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《娱乐余韵》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的……
I suppose they've been sufficiently Christianised that that tradition is starting to fade the tradition of becoming a viking is starting to fade but it's also the the strength and the power of um the norman monarch that that william establishes um and the sense of a kind of christian commonality between all the various kingdoms um so i think that if we're talking anglo-danish relations it's very much a game of two halves well i was about to say so the first half it's it's the Danes kicking sand in the faces of the English. So what's the score? Second half. What's the score, would you say, Tom?
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余韵》。对于那些在播客前半小时感到困惑的国际听众，我应该说这是一个关于英丹关系的播客，以配合2021年举行的2020年欧洲杯半决赛……
I think it's 3-1 to Denmark, I think. 3-1 to Denmark. That's bad. If it's 3-1 at halftime on Wednesday, I shall be deeply disappointed. Well, if it's 1-3, I shall be deeply disappointed. But it's a game of two halves. It is a game of two halves. Let's see what happens in the second half.
周三晚上在温布利球场由英格兰对阵丹麦。汤姆和我非常兴奋。英格兰基本上每个人都非常兴奋，不是吗，汤姆？我想丹麦每个人也是。在汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）描述了他们在维京时代对英格兰的各种袭击之后，丹麦人在历史上的上半场以3-1领先。汤姆，我想我们现在要跨越时间了，不是吗？
We'll see. So back they go to the dressing rooms. Gareth Southgate can have a word and we'll see if the picture changes after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of
走着瞧吧。球员们回到更衣室了。加雷斯·索斯盖特可以趁机叮嘱几句，看看中场休息后局面会不会有所改观。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》。这是你每周必听的
entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. For our international listeners who are baffled after the first half hour of this podcast, I should say that this is a podcast about Anglo-Danish relations to tie in with the semi-final of Euro 2020 being played in 2021
娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在问答环节，我们还会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《余下皆历史》。对于那些在听了本期播客前三十分钟后感到困惑的国际听众，我得说明一下，这是一档关于英丹关系的播客，旨在配合2021年举办的2020年欧洲杯半决赛
at Wembley between England and Denmark on Wednesday evening. Tom and I are very excited. Everybody in England basically is very overexcited, aren't they, Tom? And I assume everybody in Denmark too. The Danes are leading after the first historical half, 3-1, after Tom Holland's description of their various assaults on England in the Viking Age. Tom, I think we're going to leap forward in time, aren't we now?
于周三晚上在温布利球场举行，对阵双方是英格兰和丹麦。汤姆和我非常兴奋。英格兰的每个人基本上都太兴奋了，对吧，汤姆？我想丹麦的每个人也一样。在汤姆·霍兰德讲述了维京时代丹麦人对英格兰的各种侵略后，丹麦人在历史性的上半场过后以3比1领先。汤姆，我想我们现在要跨越时间向前看了，对吧？
I'm not aware of the Danes doing anything in the sort of 13th,th 15th century you i mean they must be not really but nothing nothing worth discussing i think we should leap right forward do you have anything to say before we get to the stewart era no or not no cut let's let's cut let's cut to let's cut to james the first james the sixth it is the it is the proverbial game of two halves so i I have done a bit of digging into the story of Anne of Denmark, who is an extraordinary figure. So Anne of Denmark marries James VI of Scotland, who becomes James I of England. She's the second daughter of Frederick II of Denmark. So the sort of early modern period is quite a... Denmark's a pretty sizable, you know, sort of military power. And also it's Lutheran, isn't it?
我不觉得丹麦人在13世纪到15世纪之间做过什么值得讨论的事，我想我们应该直接跳过。在进入斯图亚特王朝之前，你有什么要说的吗？没有？那我们直接切入詹姆斯一世，也就是詹姆斯六世。这真是一场典型的“两半场”比赛。我稍微挖掘了一下丹麦的安妮的故事，她是一个非凡的人物。安妮嫁给了苏格兰的詹姆斯六世，也就是后来的英格兰国王詹姆斯一世。她是丹麦国王弗雷德里克二世的次女。在近代早期，丹麦是一个相当大的军事强国，而且它是路德宗国家，对吧？
It is. And so there aren't that many Lutheran kingdoms. No. And there's certainly not many Protestant kingdoms. And so that's the key. I mean, these are great days for Sweden and Denmark, actually. They're really sort of fighting for control of the Baltic and stuff. But a Danish alliance is much to be prized if you're a Protestant. So
确实。当时路德宗王国并不多，新教王国就更少了，所以这很关键。其实这对瑞典和丹麦来说都是辉煌的时期，它们在争夺波罗的海的控制权。但如果你是新教徒，丹麦的盟友身份是非常宝贵的。
James VI of Scotland is married to Anne of Denmark when she's 14. And at first they get on pretty well, but just before he's about to become King of England it all starts to go wrong. So they first fall out bizarrely because over the custody
苏格兰的詹姆斯六世在安妮14岁时娶了她。起初他们相处得还不错，但在他即将成为英格兰国王之前，一切都开始变糟了。他们第一次闹翻是因为一件奇怪的事，关于监护权。
of their son. So they're not divorced, but they still have fallen out of the custody because apparently the practice in Scotland is the eldest son is given away to be brought up. And she just thought, this is like a sort of ancestor of people sending their kids away to boarding school. To Gordonstoun.
关于他们儿子的监护权。他们没有离婚，但因为监护权闹翻了，因为当时苏格兰的习俗是长子要送出去抚养。她觉得这就像是把孩子送去寄宿学校的祖先，送去戈登斯顿公学那种地方。
Yeah, sort of incredibly vicious boarding schools like Prince Charles at the age of two or something. And Anne of Denmark is outraged that her son Henry is given to the Earl of Mar to be. And that sort of, I think that kind of creates a bit of a riff that never really heals. So then just before James comes to England, there's a thing called the Gowrie Conspiracy,
是的，就像查尔斯王子两岁时被送去的那种极其严苛的寄宿学校。安妮对她的儿子亨利被交给马尔伯爵抚养感到愤怒。我认为这造成了一道从未真正愈合的裂痕。就在詹姆斯去英格兰之前，发生了一件叫“高里阴谋”的事。
where these two guys, I think they're two guys, they have a plot to kill James. This is happening all the time in Scotland in the late 16th century and they're killed by his attendants and then not unreasonably he wants to get rid
当时有两个家伙，我想是两个人，他们密谋杀害詹姆斯。这在16世纪末的苏格兰经常发生，他们被詹姆斯的侍从杀死了。然后，詹姆斯想除掉他们的姐妹，也就是他妻子的侍女，这也不算不合理。
of their sisters who are her ladies in waiting, his wife's ladies in waiting so he says well obviously their sisters can't stay on as ladies and waiting after they've tried to kill me um the queen fair enough anna denmark is outraged by this and she stages a hunger strike but she stays in bed she won't get out of bed because she's really close to them and um eventually james mollifies her by hiring an
他说，既然她们的兄弟试图杀我，她们显然不能再留下来当侍女了。安妮对此感到愤怒，她发起了绝食抗议，她躺在床上不肯起来，因为她和那些侍女关系很好。最终，詹姆斯雇了一个杂技演员来逗她开心，想把她从床上引出来。
acrobat and sending the acrobat to entertain her and kind of lure her out of bed. Does it work? It does work. I mean, the hunger strike is over. But I think there's still bad blood because they go to England. They establish a household. He sends a message to her after a while. He says he doesn't like her English household.
这招管用吗？管用。绝食抗议结束了。但我认为他们之间仍有积怨，因为他们去了英格兰，建立了家庭。过了一段时间，他给安妮传话，说他不喜欢她的英格兰仆从。
He sends her a message. His Majesty takes her continued perversity very heinously, which I think is a marital message you don't want to receive. He sends her a message, His Majesty takes her continued perversity very heinously, which I think is a marital message you don't want to receive. And doesn't she eat his dog or something? Yes, exactly. Dead dogs. If anyone listens to this podcast for the first time, dead dogs are a theme of our podcast.
他给她传话，说“陛下对她持续的顽固感到非常愤怒”，我觉得这是你不想收到的婚姻信息。而且她是不是吃了他的狗还是怎么的？没错，死狗。如果有人第一次听这个播客，死狗是我们播客的一个主题。
And James had a dog called either Jewel or Jowler. They're quite different names, I think. I mean, you picture the dog very differently if it's called Jewel or Jowler. Anyway, Jewel or Jowler is his favourite dog. Supposedly, he's, quote, his special and most favourite hound. And she shoots him with a crossbow.
詹姆斯有一条狗，名字叫“珠宝”或“乔勒”。我觉得这两个名字差别很大，如果你叫它“珠宝”或“乔勒”，你对狗的印象会完全不同。总之，珠宝或乔勒是他最喜欢的狗。据说它是他“特别且最宠爱的猎犬”。结果她用弩把它射死了。
Just by accident or deliberately? It's really hard to make out. I had to look at the original source and it's very unclear that's quite a quite a quite a drastic move isn't it it's very drastic if your wife killed your pet dog with the crossbow i mean that's that's pretty yes i mean it's hard to come back from that james apparently i mean this is such a strange story. He was absolutely furious when he saw his dog with the crossbow bolt. He would be. And he went round in an enormous huff. And his servant said, well, it's actually the queen who did it. And at that point, supposedly, this is such a weird story.
是意外还是故意的？真的很难分辨。我查了原始资料，非常不清楚。这真是个极端的举动，不是吗？如果你的妻子用弩杀了你的宠物狗，那确实非常极端。詹姆斯显然——这故事太奇怪了——当他看到他的狗被弩箭射中时，他非常愤怒。他会生气的。当他的仆人告诉他是王后干的时，据说——这故事太诡异了——
He calms down. He's not so angry. He sent her a jewel worth £2,000. So that suggests the dog's name is Jewel, surely. Right, which is the equivalent. Well, maybe there's some confusion, though. Well, which is the equivalent of about £10 million today. And he says, quote, it was a legacy from his dear dead dog.
他冷静下来了，没那么生气了。他送给她一件价值2000英镑的珠宝。这说明狗的名字肯定叫“珠宝”。没错，这相当于今天的1000万英镑。他说，这是“他亲爱的死狗留下的遗产”。
I mean, that's worthy of the Jeremy Thorpe scandal. Yeah, that's great. Why would you do that? Why didn't we remember this when we were going through our list of famous dead dogs? Well, we didn't know about it. I mean, let's be honest. When you say remember it,
这简直可以媲美杰里米·索普丑闻了。太棒了。你为什么要那样做？我们在列举著名死狗名单时为什么没想起这个？好吧，我们当时不知道。老实说，当你问“记得吗”的时候，
I mean, we didn't know it until about a day ago. Oh, no, I think... Did you know this? Yes, I did. I didn't know this. I did. I knew that she killed his dog. And suddenly, thinking about it, it came back to me.
我是说，我们直到一天前才知道。哦，不，我想……你知道这件事吗？是的，我知道。我不知道。我知道她杀了他的狗。突然想起这件事，记忆就回来了。
Yeah. Now, of course, I suppose what lies behind a lot of this, though, Tom, is that James I's sexuality is in some doubt, isn't it? So I think by this point. And he's slobbered. Yeah. His tongue's too big for his mouth. Yes.
是的。现在，汤姆，我想这一切背后的原因，是詹姆斯一世的性取向有些疑点，对吧？我想到了这一点。而且他流口水。是的，他的舌头对他的嘴来说太大了。
So he's obsessed by witches. His tongue's too big for his mouth. He slobbers. He's always going after young men with very long legs. The Duke of Buckingham. He's got a fancy for the Duke of Buckingham. So presented with all this, this Danish queen just driven mad. But from the point of view of Anglo-Danish rivalry,
他痴迷于女巫。他的舌头太大，总是流口水。他总是追逐那些长腿的年轻人，比如白金汉公爵。他看上了白金汉公爵。面对这一切，这位丹麦王后简直要疯了。但从英丹竞争的角度来看，
I want to point out he is, of course, Scottish. Yes, although he's also the King of England. He is the King of England. I mean, we're not just subsuming Scotland. There is a further dimension to this. Yes. Pointed out by none other than Simon Sharma. Yes.
我想指出他当然是苏格兰人。是的，尽管他也是英格兰国王。他是英格兰国王。我们不仅仅是吞并了苏格兰。这还有更深的一层维度。是的，西蒙·沙玛也指出了这一点。
Queen Anne. Isn't it weird that Hamlet was performed before king james and and um queen anne at hampton court especially since james's mother's story not on altogether unlike gertrude well this is the thing i think this lies behind the dog murder yeah right she has moved to england she's moved to scotland first then to england uh she's been forced to watch plays about Denmark that paint Danish history in a very dark and convoluted light. But, I mean, so on the Shakespeare angle, James, when he went to pick her up, he does visit Elsinore, which is the setting for Hamlet.
安妮王后。哈姆雷特在汉普顿宫为詹姆斯国王和安妮王后表演，这不是很奇怪吗？尤其是考虑到詹姆斯母亲的故事和格特鲁德的故事并不完全不同。我认为这就是狗被杀背后的原因。她搬到了英格兰，先是苏格兰，然后是英格兰。她被迫观看关于丹麦的戏剧，这些戏剧以非常黑暗和扭曲的视角描绘丹麦历史。但从莎士比亚的角度来看，詹姆斯去接她时，确实访问了赫尔辛格，也就是《哈姆雷特》的背景地。
Have you been to Elsinore? I have been to Elsinore. It's great. It's a great castle. It has a remarkable thing among tourist attractions, which I almost admire them forore it's great it has it's a great castle it has a remarkable thing among tourist attractions which I almost
你去过赫尔辛格吗？我去过。那是一座很棒的城堡。它在旅游景点中有一个非凡之处，我甚至有点佩服他们，
admire them for because it's so shameless you have to when we went you have to follow a very particular route
因为太无耻了。当你去的时候，你必须遵循一条非常特定的路线，
you can't sort of deviate they have kind of cellars don't they it's a one-way system yeah but the one-way system leads you twice
你不能偏离。他们有地窖，对吧？这是一个单向系统。是的，但这个单向系统会带你两次
through the gift shop through different parts of the gift shop I didn't remember that but obviously blank but if you travel around with a child, you know, you really do notice it because you have faced two barrages of
穿过礼品店，穿过礼品店的不同部分。我不记得了，但如果你带着孩子旅行，你真的会注意到，因为你面临着两次
can I buy a sword? Can I buy a Hamlet's helmet or something? Yeah, so anyway, Anne really matters because her brother is going to play a big part in, well, he always plays. Well, Dominic yeah so just on the shakespeare theme there are two other famous tragedies that have an anglo-danish link one is one is macbeth because when they're coming back so when ann is is and james are coming back um
“我可以买把剑吗？我可以买哈姆雷特的头盔吗？”之类的轰炸。总之，安妮真的很重要，因为她的兄弟将扮演重要角色。多米尼克，关于莎士比亚的主题，还有两部著名的悲剧有英丹联系。一个是《麦克白》，因为当安妮和詹姆斯回来时，
across the north sea the terrible storms and james blames this on witches so that's kind of part of what turbo charges his obsession with witchcraft and there's an allusion to this in in Macbeth with the witches that okay that but the other one is so Christian IV who is Anne's I think younger brother and a very powerful king yes massive lad um he comes over on a state visit he does I was going to mention this. I'm gutted that you've got him first. I'm sorry.
穿过北海时遇到了可怕的风暴，詹姆斯把这归咎于女巫，这加剧了他对巫术的痴迷，在《麦克白》中女巫的部分对此有暗示。另一个是克里斯蒂安四世，也就是安妮的弟弟，一位非常强大的国王，大块头。他来进行国事访问。我正要提这个，被你抢先了，我很沮丧。抱歉。
I'm sorry. But the reason I mentioned it with the Shakespeare context is that they have a kind of rendezvous on a ship. So James comes down on a rather wussy barge. And Christian has this massive ship. And they meet up and have a rendezvous on the ship like Antony and Octavian in Antony Cleopatra. Oh, that's a good fact. James Shapiro, in his book on Shakespeare in 1606, suggests that this was the inspiration for that passage in Antony and Cleopatra. Don't know whether that's true or not, but it's a Shakespearean Anglo-Danish angle.
抱歉。但我提到它是因为莎士比亚的背景，他们在船上有过一次会面。詹姆斯坐着一艘相当寒酸的驳船，而克里斯蒂安有一艘巨大的船。他们像《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》中的安东尼和屋大维一样在船上会面。这是个好事实。詹姆斯·夏皮罗在他关于1606年莎士比亚的书里认为，这就是《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》中那段情节的灵感来源。不知道是不是真的，但这是一个莎士比亚式的英丹角度。
See, what I was going to say about Christian IV, he comes over on a state visit in 1606 to visit his sister, and it goes incredibly well well stroked badly because the Danes are very hard drinking and they all drink a colossal amount and everybody at court is struck by this and they stage at James's country house they put on a mask of Solomon and the Queen of Sheba and it turns into an absolute fiasco because the Danes have all been drinking all day and they encourage the English to drink as well. And many of the actors are so drunk they fall over and can't say their lines.
关于克里斯蒂安四世，他在1606年进行国事访问去探望他的姐姐，结果非常糟糕，因为丹麦人酒量很大，喝得非常多，宫廷里的每个人都对此感到震惊。在詹姆斯的乡间别墅，他们上演了《所罗门与示巴女王》的假面舞剧，结果变成了一场彻底的闹剧，因为丹麦人整天都在喝酒，还怂恿英国人也喝。许多演员醉得摔倒，连台词都说不出来。
A custom more honoured in the breach than in the observance. Very good. As Hamlet would say. Very good. Very good. Okay, I think that's enough about Queen Anne because we've got to move on because we've still got lots more to cover. Christian IV is still in the... he's hovering about because... Oh yes, of course, of course.
“与其遵守，不如打破的习俗。”很好，正如哈姆雷特所说。很好。好了，关于安妮王后的讨论够多了，我们得继续前进，因为还有很多内容要涵盖。克里斯蒂安四世还在……他在徘徊，因为……哦，是的，当然。
Because... And now we've got Dan Jackson's tweet. Yeah, because, right, Charles I, who is half Danish. I'd never thought of him as half Danish. But Charles I is basically the personification of English history. Half Dane,
因为……现在我们有丹·杰克逊的推文了。是的，因为查理一世是半个丹麦人。我从没想过他是半个丹麦人。但查理一世基本上是英国历史的化身。半个丹麦人，
well, half Scottish, actually, isn't he? Yes. He, at the outbreak of the Civil War, jackson points out asks christian the fourth for military aid something i did not know at all and the danes have you got have you got the tweet there tom from i have yes so so dan dan jackson who of course uh author of northumbrians who appeared on our um north south divide episode says if you're musing on Anglo-Danish relations, then this is intriguing.
其实是半个苏格兰人，对吧？是的。杰克逊指出，在内战爆发时，他向克里斯蒂安四世寻求军事援助，这一点我完全不知道。汤姆，你有那条推文吗？我有。丹·杰克逊，也就是《诺森布里亚人》的作者，曾出现在我们的南北分歧那一集，他说如果你在思考英丹关系，这很有趣。
In 1642, Charles I asked his uncle, Christian IV, for military aid, but in return, the Danes wanted Orkney, Shetland, and to gain possession of Newcastle in Porn. And the motive for this seems to have been commercial, as Newcastle was renowned for her coal and salt industries. So, you know, Danish Newcastle. Yeah.
1642年，查理一世向他的叔叔克里斯蒂安四世寻求军事援助，但作为回报，丹麦人想要奥克尼群岛、设得兰群岛，并获得纽卡斯尔的控制权。动机似乎是商业上的，因为纽卡斯尔以煤炭和盐业闻名。所以，丹麦人的纽卡斯尔。
They wanted the Danor back, basically, clearly. Yeah, basically, yeah. And they didn't get it. But it didn't work out, did it? No. So Christian IV later, I believe, sent some people with ships and a load of armour to offer to Charles I.
他们基本上是想拿回丹麦区。是的，基本上是这样。他们没得逞。但事情没成，对吧？没有。所以克里斯蒂安四世后来派了一些船只和一批盔甲给查理一世。
And somehow they are detained by parliamentarians and beaten up or something and then sent back, and nothing comes of it. So that's a great missed opportunity for Denmark. And Dominic, do we have anything on Anglo-Danish relations between that and 1801? We don't, but 1801 is such a great date. I think we should get straight to 1801. So tell us why 1801 is a great date.
不知怎么的，他们被议会派扣留并殴打，然后被遣送回国，什么也没发生。这对丹麦来说是一个巨大的错失良机。多米尼克，在那之后到1801年之间，我们还有关于英丹关系的内容吗？没有，但1801年是一个伟大的年份。我想我们应该直接谈谈1801年。告诉我们为什么1801年是一个伟大的年份。
So 1801, the Napoleonic Wars, the British have tried to... The French and the British have imposed rival blockades on each other, and all the Baltic countries, Russia, Prussia, Denmark, Sweden, they want to break the British blockade.
1801年，拿破仑战争时期，法国和英国对彼此实施了相互封锁，所有的波罗的海国家，俄罗斯、普鲁士、丹麦、瑞典，都想打破英国的封锁。
They want to carry on trading. And the British are having none of this. Nelson, who's been off around the world, is sent off to the Baltic and is told, you know, you have to impose the blockade and stop these people breaking out. And especially we're worried that they might join the French. Nelson says, well, in his sort of swashbuckling spirit, he says, well, let's just let's just blow them all up. So he goes off into Copenhagen harbour and the Admiral Parker waits behind him. And on the 2nd of April, 1801, Nelson attacks.
他们想继续贸易。英国人对此绝不答应。纳尔逊被派往波罗的海，被告知要实施封锁，阻止这些人突围。我们特别担心他们会加入法国。纳尔逊以他那种冒险精神说，好吧，让我们把他们都炸掉。于是他进入哥本哈根港，帕克海军上将跟在他后面。1801年4月2日，纳尔逊发动了进攻。
And he attacks with such force, there's huge amounts of smoke all over the harbour. And the Admiral sends him a signal to withdraw, basically worried that British ships are running aground. Now, the Admiral kind of knows that if things are going well, Nelson will ignore it, and that's precisely what Nelson does. So Nelson says to his flag captain, the man called Thomas Foley, he's been told there's a signal.
他以巨大的力量进攻，港口到处都是浓烟。海军上将发信号让他撤退，主要是担心英国船只搁浅。海军上将知道，如果进展顺利，纳尔逊会无视信号，而纳尔逊正是这么做的。所以纳尔逊对他的旗舰船长托马斯·福利说，他被告知有信号。
He says to Foley, you know, Foley, I have only one eye. I have a right to be blind sometimes. And he lifts the telescope and he puts it to the blind eye because he's been blinded in Corsica in 1794. And he says, I really do not see the signal, which of course he doesn't. So we carry on attacking. We capture six Danish ships.
他对福利说：“福利，我只有一只眼睛。我有权偶尔失明。”他举起望远镜，放在那只失明的眼睛上，因为他在1794年的科西嘉岛战役中失明了。他说：“我真的没看到信号。”当然他没看到。所以我们继续进攻。我们俘获了六艘丹麦船只。
We sink three of them. And as a reward for this, Nelson is made Viscount Nelson of the Nile, which is a great title. Now I will say, this story is probably untrue. I mean, that's such a shame. So Roger Knight, who is Nelson's biographer, says this stuff about the telescope is probably
我们击沉了三艘。作为奖励，纳尔逊被封为尼罗河纳尔逊子爵，这是一个很棒的头衔。现在我要说，这个故事可能是假的。真可惜。纳尔逊的传记作者罗杰·奈特说，关于望远镜的事可能是
an apocryphal story created after the event. But that needn't stop it being an inspiration for anyone threatened with substitution. On Wednesday night, I do not see it. My blind eye has turned. And then going on to score the winning goal.
事后编造的伪史。但这并不妨碍它成为任何面临被换下场的人的灵感。周三晚上，我没看到。我的盲眼转过去了。然后继续打进致胜球。
Yes. So that might be the parallel. Maybe. So we have that, but then we also have another attack in 1807. Yeah. So if you're Danish listening to this, that's the one you'll probably remember,
是的。所以这可能是个类比。也许吧。所以我们有这个，但1807年还有另一次袭击。是的。如果你是听这个节目的丹麦人，那才是你可能记得的，
not 1801. Because this is really bad, because we basically just, it's a preemptive strike, isn't it? Yeah. We're worried about them joining the French again. This time we just think, go for it. Yeah.
而不是1801年。因为这真的很糟糕，因为我们基本上只是……这是一次先发制人的打击，对吧？是的。我们担心他们再次加入法国。这次我们只是想，干吧。
The British land, 30,000 troops. They bombard Copenhagen. Go on, Tom. You've got something to say. Okay. Well, I just, yeah. So this is pretty shameful, actually, which is obviously why people in England don't know about it.
英国人登陆了3万军队。他们轰炸了哥本哈根。继续，汤姆。你有什么要说的。好吧，这其实很可耻，这就是为什么英国人不知道这件事。
But one person who does know about it unexpectedly to me is Lord Frost, who, of course, was the Brexit negotiator. The chief Brexit. Has he threatened this? He should threaten this during Brexit negotiations. No, but before he became the Brexit negotiator, he was a diplomat. Right. And he was the ambassador to Copenhagen. So he tweeted yesterday, I have something you may be interested in for your Anglo-Danish episode,
但有一个人出乎意料地知道这件事，那就是弗罗斯特勋爵，也就是英国脱欧谈判代表。首席脱欧代表。他威胁过这个吗？他应该在脱欧谈判中威胁这个。不，但在成为脱欧谈判代表之前，他是一名外交官。他是驻哥本哈根大使。所以他昨天发推文说，我有一些你可能对英丹那一集感兴趣的东西，
my own rough translation into English done when I was ambassador in Denmark of the pamphlet we published with the Danish authorities about the 1807 siege of Copenhagen. Tom, are you receiving advice about the podcast from our chief Brexit negotiator?
这是我担任丹麦大使时，我们与丹麦当局共同发布的关于1807年哥本哈根围城的宣传册的草译。汤姆，你是在接受我们的首席脱欧谈判代表关于播客的建议吗？
Yes, I am. Yes. Oh, i am yes oh yeah that's a nice and there's some there's a fantastic description of it of um of all the uh the kind of the gun you know the firing these um missiles that they developed and uh yeah so they congreve congreve congreve rockets which are the same invention of the um of the kingdom of my saw that then got developed by congreve and fired at Copenhagen. They're the rockets that are bursting in the Star Spangled Banner. Yes. We use them at the same time.
是的，我是。哦，是的，那很好。那里有对他们开发的导弹的精彩描述，康格里夫火箭，也就是迈索尔王国发明的，后来被康格里夫开发并射向哥本哈根。它们就是《星条旗》中提到的那些火箭。是的，我们当时也用了。
Yes, they're very simple. We fire them at Copenhagen. But we also have another tweet from Tapani Simajoki, who is a Lutheran pastor in Hampshire. You've got all the contacts, haven't you? Yes. Yes. Yes. And he discusses a hymn, Built on the Rock, The Church Doth Stand, which he says was inspired retrospectively by the deliberate destruction of the Church of Our Lady, which was a medieval church, by the British in the Battle of Copenhagen. A famously godly lot, the British gunners used the spire for range practice. Yes.
是的，它们很简单。我们把它们射向哥本哈根。但我们还有另一条来自汉普郡的路德宗牧师塔帕尼·西马约基的推文。你有人脉，对吧？是的。他讨论了一首赞美诗《建立在磐石上，教会屹立不倒》，他说这首歌的灵感来自于英国人在哥本哈根战役中故意摧毁圣母教堂，那是一座中世纪教堂。英国炮手以教堂尖顶作为射击练习目标。
Well, this is true. We did. So our gunners did use the church spires um to get their sights and they just blasted the hell out of them yeah so there we go so a lot of help there from yes from a very a brexit uh finnish uh axis there so thank you to lord frost and to the parney for for uh for that one other quick um one of One other quick Napoleonic Wars reference is that to honour, in tribute to Nelson's heroics at Copenhagen,
好吧，这是真的。我们确实这么做了。我们的炮手确实利用教堂尖顶来瞄准，然后把它们炸得稀巴烂。所以，从一位芬兰脱欧派那里得到了很多帮助，谢谢弗罗斯特勋爵和塔帕尼。关于拿破仑战争的另一个快速参考是，为了向纳尔逊在哥本哈根的英勇表现致敬，
if heroics you can call them, the Duke of Wellington called his horse Copenhagen. Of course he did. He was foaled during the attack. And the nearest Wellington came to death at the Battle of Waterloo was when he got off Copenhagen at the end. Copenhagen tried to kick him
如果那能被称为英勇的话，威灵顿公爵给他的马取名为“哥本哈根”。当然他会这么做。它是在袭击期间出生的。威灵顿在滑铁卢战役中最接近死亡的一次，就是最后从“哥本哈根”身上下来时。哥本哈根试图踢他，
and almost kicked him in the head, which would have killed him. And Copenhagen is still buried, I believe, at the Duke of Wellington's house at Stratford Say. Stratfield Say, sorry. Wonderful. Yes, there you go. Okay, well, there you go.
差点踢中他的头，那会杀了他。我相信“哥本哈根”至今仍埋在威灵顿公爵位于斯特拉特菲尔德塞的家中。太棒了。好了，就是这样。
Now, I think you have an excellent, excellent story suggested by Nelson Jones. Am I right? Yes, I do. so to read nelson's um what i've got nelson's suite if you don't have it yeah no i got it um so he's this is on the anglo-danish theme some will say nelson others the great northern army but for me the absolute low point in anglo-danish relations was has christian anderson outaying his welcome at Dickens' house, which is indeed a great story of Anglo-Danish hostility. So go on, Tom.
现在，我想你有一个由纳尔逊·琼斯建议的精彩故事。对吗？是的。我读一下纳尔逊的推文。这是关于英丹主题的，有人会说纳尔逊，有人会说北方大军，但对我来说，英丹关系绝对的低谷是汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生在狄更斯家住得太久，这确实是一个关于英丹敌对的伟大故事。继续，汤姆。
You take us into the story. So Hans Christian Andersen, Hans Christian Andersen and Dickens, probably two colossal 19th century writers. Hans Christian Andersen, author of The Little Mermaid, statue of which stands in Copenhagen to this day. He comes to England when his stories first get published
你带我们进入这个故事。汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生和狄更斯，可能是两位19世纪的巨匠。安徒生，《海的女儿》的作者，至今在哥本哈根还有雕像。当他的故事首次以英文出版时，他来到英国进行图书巡回宣传。
in English on a kind of book tour. And he meets with Dickens in 1847 at an aristocratic soiree. And Dickens, very polite, says, oh, I like your stuff. Hans Christian Andersen idolises Dickens and is all over him and he goes back to uh copenhagen and basically writes to dickens pretty much every day in the most effusive terms and dickens kind of dead bats this and dead bats this but had made the terrible mistake we've all done it we've all done things like this, haven't we? I say, oh, well, if you come back to London, you must look me up.
1847年，他在一场贵族聚会上遇到了狄更斯。狄更斯非常有礼貌地说：“哦，我喜欢你的作品。”安徒生崇拜狄更斯，对他纠缠不休，回到哥本哈根后，基本上每天都用最热情的措辞给狄更斯写信。狄更斯对此冷处理，但他犯了一个我们都犯过的可怕错误，我们都做过这种事，不是吗？我说：“哦，如果你再来伦敦，一定要来找我。”
Which Anderson, in due course, in 1857, so a decade later, does. And he goes to Gad's Hill, Dickens' house. Well, wait a second, Tom. Does he not say, I'm going to come for at most, at most, yeah, something like, it's either two days or two weeks, but anyway, it's a short period of time.
安徒生在十年后的1857年确实这么做了。他去了狄更斯的家，盖兹山庄。等等，汤姆。他不是说最多待两天或两周吗？总之，时间很短。
So he turns out at Gad's Hill, Dickens' house out by Rochester. And it's a terrible time for Dickens because his marriage is breaking up. He's just published a little Dorrit, which hasn't done very well. And he's in the midst of rehearsing for a play with Wilkie Collins. So he's got lots on his plate, as Christian Anderson turns up, and is an absolutely monstrous house guest. So first of all, he declares that it's the custom in Denmark for the son of the host to shave the guest every day.
所以他出现在盖兹山庄。这对狄更斯来说是一段糟糕的时光，因为他的婚姻正在破裂。他刚出版的《小杜丽》卖得不好。他正忙着和威尔基·柯林斯排练一部戏。所以他忙得不可开交，安徒生出现了，成了一个绝对可怕的房客。首先，他宣称丹麦的习俗是主人的儿子每天要为客人刮胡子。
That's such a high-risk gambit from a guest, isn't it? I mean, it goes wrong it is and so dickens's sons refuse to do this and they send him off into rochester to have his shaving done there hans christian anderson won't leave dickens alone and they're going into a dinner party dickens offers his arm to a lady hans christian anderson rushes in elbows the lady's side takes his arm and clings to it. This isn't the dumb thing either. That's quite strange behaviour, isn't it, really?
这对客人来说是一个高风险的赌注，不是吗？结果搞砸了。狄更斯的儿子们拒绝这样做，他们把他打发到罗切斯特去刮胡子。安徒生不让狄更斯清静，他们去参加晚宴，狄更斯挽着一位女士，安徒生冲过来，挤开女士，挽住狄更斯的手臂。这太奇怪了，不是吗？
He goes to watch Dickens perform in the play, The Frozen Deep, and he very, very ostentatiously bursts into tears and sobs the whole way through it, throwing all the actors off course. He gets a bad review and hurls himself into a flower bed sobbing and beating the beating the flower bed with his hands i'd love to see some of the danish players do that on wednesday great wouldn't it and essentially he stays for weeks and weeks he says five weeks in the end and when he goes um he he's dismissed by dickens's daughter as a bony bore dickens writes large
他去看狄更斯演的戏《冰冷的深渊》，他非常夸张地大哭大闹，打乱了所有演员的节奏。他得到了一篇差评，于是把自己扔进花坛里，哭着捶打花坛。我很想看到丹麦球员周三那样做，那会很棒，不是吗？他基本上待了几个星期，最后他说待了五周。他走的时候，狄更斯的女儿称他为“骨瘦如柴的无聊鬼”。狄更斯写了大量
numbers of bitchy letters one of of them to Lord John Russell, his former prime minister, in which he claims that he complains about Hans Christian Andersen's linguistic skills. I saw that. He said he doesn't speak French, doesn't speak English, can't even write Danish.
刻薄的信，其中一封写给前首相约翰·罗素勋爵，抱怨安徒生的语言能力。我看到了。他说他不会说法语，不会说英语，甚至写不好丹麦语。
But whether Dickens could speak Danish, I doubt. I mean, I imagine any Danish listeners will be amused at the idea of an English person insulting the Danes for their lack of linguistic ability. That's very true, yeah. I wouldn't advise any of England's players to do that on Wednesday. I think that would be very foolish.
但狄更斯会不会说丹麦语，我很怀疑。我想任何丹麦听众都会觉得英国人侮辱丹麦人语言能力差很可笑。确实如此。我不建议任何英格兰球员周三那样做，那会非常愚蠢。
So that's obviously a sort of... That's a great story. I mean, that's a goal for England. Yes. And actually, if things weren't going badly enough for Denmark, not long after that, just a few years after that, the Danes suffered
所以这显然是一个……这是一个伟大的故事。对英格兰来说是一个进球。是的。而且，如果丹麦的情况还不够糟糕，没过几年，丹麦人就遭受了
this sort of great trauma, don't they, of losing Schleswig-Holstein. That's all a shambles, but I'm not even going to try to redo it. Schleswig-Holstein. Is that about right?
失去石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因的巨大创伤。那是一团糟，但我甚至不想尝试重述它。石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因。对吗？
That's right. So this is the most, one of the famously the most complicated diplomatic dilemma in European history, isn't it? And Britain could have intervened to save the Danes, but refused to. So the Duchess of Schleswig and Holstein are attached to Denmark. They're in personal union with the Danish crown, but they're not part of Denmark. They're part of the German...
没错。这是欧洲历史上最复杂的外交困境之一，不是吗？英国本可以干预拯救丹麦，但拒绝了。石勒苏益格和荷尔斯泰因公国附属于丹麦。它们与丹麦王室有个人联合，但不是丹麦的一部分。它们是德国的一部分……
Holstein is part of the German Confederation. So there's a very confusing picture. And there was a thing called the London Protocol, which had been agreed to ensure, I don't know, to ensure the sort of integrity of Denmark, but also the integrity of these other places. Nobody understood it. Lord Palmerston famously said,
荷尔斯泰因是德意志邦联的一部分。所以情况非常混乱。有一个叫《伦敦议定书》的东西，旨在确保丹麦的完整，也确保其他地方的完整。没人理解它。帕默斯顿勋爵曾有名言：
only three people have ever really understood the Schleswig-Holstein business. The prince consort who is dead, the German professor who has gone mad, and I who have forgotten all about it. That's pretty much how I feel about a lot of things we talk about in this podcast. The Danes
“只有三个人真正理解石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因问题：已故的王夫，疯了的德国教授，以及已经完全忘记这件事的我。”这和我对我们在播客中讨论的很多事情的感觉差不多。丹麦人
try to make Schleswig-Holstein part of Denmark basically to sort of rationalise it all. The Prussians and the Austrians invade. There is a huge amount of hullabaloo in England. People say we should intervene to save the Danes. But it gets swallowed up, doesn't it? It does get swallowed up. Palmerston wanted to, despite saying he knew nothing, he'd forgotten all about it, he actually wanted to save the Danes. But it gets swallowed up, doesn't it? It does get swallowed up. Palmerston wanted to, despite saying he knew nothing,
试图让石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因成为丹麦的一部分，基本上是为了合理化这一切。普鲁士人和奥地利人入侵了。英国国内一片哗然。人们说我们应该干预拯救丹麦。但它被吞没了，不是吗？确实被吞没了。帕默斯顿想干预，尽管他说他什么都不知道，已经忘记了，但他确实想拯救丹麦。但它被吞没了，不是吗？确实被吞没了。帕默斯顿想干预，尽管他说他什么都不知道，
he'd forgotten all about it, he actually wanted to help the Danes, to do something to help them. And Queen Victoria said no. She was too pro-German. And this is the first building block in the creation of Germany. It's the first of the three great wars that Bismarck fights. He fights the Danes, then he fights... So he's fighting progressively...
他已经忘记了，但他确实想帮助丹麦，做点什么来帮助他们。但维多利亚女王拒绝了。她太亲德了。这是德国建立的第一个基石。这是俾斯麦发动的这三场大战中的第一场。他先打丹麦，然后打……所以他是在逐步……
It's a bit like a tournament. He's fighting progressively tougher opponents. The Danes the austrians and then the french but you know this also it has a link with the very beginnings of this podcast because it along the the the neck of the peninsula separating denmark from germany yes is and again danish listeners will probably laugh at my pronunciation. The Danavirka. Very good. Danavirka. The Danavirka. That's Swedish. You said that in Swedish.
这有点像锦标赛。他是在逐步挑战更强的对手。丹麦、奥地利，然后是法国。但这与我们播客的开端也有联系，因为在分隔丹麦和德国的半岛颈部，是的，丹麦听众可能会嘲笑我的发音。丹内维尔克。很好。丹内维尔克。那是瑞典语。你用瑞典语说的。
Yeah, I know. I'm drifting off. The great earthwork built in about, begun in about 650, continued across the early Middle Ages by legend, commissioned by the mother of uh harold bluetooth and i'm still standing there when the schleswig-holstein crisis erupts how can we you can say it so so easily well that's my master of mastery of 19th century continental history dominic and of scandinavian much to learn from clearly yeah anyway so i reckon i reckon that that has got
是的，我知道。我走神了。这个伟大的土方工程始于650年左右，在中世纪早期持续修建，传说是由哈拉尔·蓝牙的母亲委托修建的。当石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因危机爆发时，它还在那里。你怎么能说得这么容易？好吧，这就是我对19世纪欧洲历史和斯堪的纳维亚历史的掌握，显然还有很多要学的。总之，我认为这让
england up to, I think we've gone into the lead there. Do you think so? I think... So I reckon we're 3-1. Well, I think there's one more... Sorry, sorry,
英格兰领先了。你觉得呢？我觉得……我觉得我们3-1领先。好吧，我想还有一件事……抱歉，抱歉，
3-4. I think there's one more thing we should mention, which is again a suggestion from Dan Jackson. Ah, yes.
3-4。我想还有一件事我们应该提一下，这也是丹·杰克逊的建议。啊，是的。
Okay, so I reckon we've won. Right. But we want to end on a note of amity and brotherhood. Yes. And a reminder of the fact that there's a lot to celebrate. Yeah.
好吧，我认为我们赢了。但我们想以友好和兄弟情谊结束。是的。并提醒大家有很多值得庆祝的事情。
Denmark's a great country. I love Denmark. I've been to Denmark on holiday. I think it's an absolutely splendid country. I like it because it's like, frankly, I mean, this is a terrible indictment of me, but I like it because it's quite like England. It's also quite like the Netherlands. Yes, it is. But I think it's my wife's favourite place to go on holiday.
丹麦是一个伟大的国家。我爱丹麦。我去过丹麦度假。我觉得它是一个非常棒的国家。我喜欢它，因为坦率地说——这对我来说是一个可怕的指控——我喜欢它是因为它很像英格兰。它也和荷兰很像。是的，确实。但我认为这是我妻子最喜欢的度假地。
Is it Denmark? Yeah, she doesn't. She burns very easily, so she hates the Mediterranean. What she likes is kind of faintly drizzly places with bicycles. Yeah, good cafes. Nice brick buildings. Yeah, Netherlands and Denmark, that's our idea of heaven. That's all good. So tell us. That's their idea of heaven. That's all good.
是丹麦吗？是的，她不喜欢地中海，因为她很容易晒伤。她喜欢那种有点细雨蒙蒙、有自行车的地方。是的，好的咖啡馆。漂亮的砖房。是的，荷兰和丹麦，那是我们心目中的天堂。那很好。所以告诉我们。那是他们的天堂。那很好。
So let's go to Dan Jackson. Yes. So Dan basically sent this picture of a memorial in Newcastle Cathedral. And the memorial reads, In memory of Danish seamen of all ranks who gave their lives in the service of their country in the years 1939 to 1945. When you read their names, remember that they died for Denmark.
所以让我们谈谈丹·杰克逊。是的。丹发了一张纽卡斯尔大教堂纪念碑的照片。纪念碑上写着：“纪念在1939年至1945年间为国捐躯的丹麦海员。当你读到他们的名字时，请记住他们为丹麦而死。”
They died for freedom so that we, like them, might live as free Danes. Very stirring. And the history behind that is that Denmark, when it was attacked by the Germans, it surrendered in six hours. I mean, they basically had no... 9th of April, 1940.
“他们为自由而死，这样我们就能像他们一样，作为自由的丹麦人生活。”非常感人。背后的历史是，丹麦在被德国人攻击时，六小时就投降了。我的意思是，他们基本上没有……1940年4月9日。
Exactly. They surrendered before breakfast, I mean, literally at breakfast, the Germans having attacked overnight. And all the Danish ships that could sailed to Britain and were put under Allied flags with a Danish crew. And the home of the Danish fleet was Newcastle. So Danish seamen settled in Newcastle for the duration of the war fleet was Newcastle. So Danish seamen settled in Newcastle for the duration of the war. They had Danish clubs, they had Danish church, they had a sort of part of the harbour that was called the Danish Pool.
没错。他们在早餐前就投降了，字面意思是在早餐时，德国人连夜发动了袭击。所有能航行的丹麦船只都驶向英国，在盟军旗帜下由丹麦船员驾驶。丹麦舰队的基地就是纽卡斯尔。所以丹麦海员在战争期间定居在纽卡斯尔。他们有丹麦俱乐部，有丹麦教堂，港口的一部分被称为“丹麦池”。
And afterwards they opened a church in Newcastle with a kind of book of remembrance and stuff. And eventually that closed down once the Danish presence dwindled and it moved into the cathedral. But Newcastle, which of course Christian IV had claimed, had wanted in 1642, it ended up becoming a little bit of Denmark. And there is kind of a little bit of Newcastle that is a bit of Denmark
后来他们在纽卡斯尔开了一座教堂，里面有纪念册之类的东西。随着丹麦人的减少，它最终关闭并搬进了大教堂。但纽卡斯尔，也就是克里斯蒂安四世在1642年声称想要的地方，最终变成了一点点丹麦。纽卡斯尔确实有一小部分是丹麦，
in the form of this memorial. So it's a lovely, lovely story. It is a wonderful story and I think a really good note on which to end. Because I think it has been a theme throughout these episodes that we've done on the rivalry between England and the various countries that our football team has been playing. But again and again, there's this emphasis on the way as well in which relations have been good and rich and productive as well. I think that's the right note on which to end. Even with the Scots. Even with the Scots, yes.
以这座纪念碑的形式存在。所以这是一个可爱、可爱的故事。这是一个美妙的故事，我认为这是一个很好的结束语。因为我认为在我们讨论英格兰足球队比赛对手的这些集数中，这一直是一个主题。但一次又一次，我们强调了关系如何变得良好、丰富和富有成效。我认为这是结束的正确基调。即使是和苏格兰人。即使是和苏格兰人，是的。
Right. So we will see you next time. Maybe, who knows, I hope I'm not jumping the gun, there might be a chance for one more bonus podcast before the tournament is over. Anglo-Italian relations, but that is all down to the Danes.
好了。所以我们下次见。也许，谁知道呢，我希望我没有操之过急，在锦标赛结束前可能还有机会再做一个奖励播客。英意关系，但这完全取决于丹麦人。
If the wrath of the Dane descends on the England football team as it did on Lindisfarne and on East Anglia, we will not be back with that. But if we manage to do as King Alfred did and defy the wrath of the Northmen, then hopefully we'll be back with either.
如果丹麦人的愤怒像降临在林迪斯法恩和东盎格利亚那样降临到英格兰足球队身上，我们就不会再做那一期了。但如果我们能像阿尔弗雷德大王那样抵御北方人的愤怒，那么希望我们能回来。
And let's hope for none of the conduct that we saw at Wilton right at the beginning of the podcast. Let's hope not. On that note, goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
让我们希望不要出现我们在播客开头看到的威尔顿那样的行为。希望不要。以此结束，再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。